bonsoir le ministère de la culture en
partenariat avec la région ile-de-france
et les magasins but m'a missionné pour
réaliser un audit de la cérémonie alors
ça a l'air chiant dit comme ça mais
c'est possible
ces lugubres donc c'est pas pareil donc
j'ai audit et j'ai regardé les 44
dernières cérémonies et faut pas être
alarmiste il ya des choses qui roule il
ya des choses qui roule d'un point de
vue sanitaire
par exemple c'est très correct à part un
orgelet de catherine jacob en 2002 et
une invasion de punaises de lit en salle
pleyel en début de matinée
tout va bien alors bien sûr d'un point
de vue comptable il va falloir
régulariser des choses notamment
vis-à-vis du fouquet's vous n'êtes pas
invité toute l'année j'ai par exemple un
menu gourmet impayées par noémie merlan
en juin 2012
et inversement g1 merlan impayées par
olivier gourmet en 2002 d'un point de
vue structurel à présent pour avoir moi
même essayé d'intégrer l'académie
cette année je propose de mettre fin à
ce système mafieux de parrainage c'est
trop compliqué c'est trop compliqué de
trouver des gens qui vous prennent dans
ce métier moi j'ai sollicité patrick
bruel
il m'a dit non apparemment c'est pas
souvent ensuite j'ai demandé à fabrice
luchini qui m'a demandé si s'emballe en
dernier recours j'ai demandé à audrey
fleurot elle a dit oui mais elle n'a pas
dû comprendre parce que j'ai pas reçu le
coffret des césar j'ai reçu toute la
gamme intime de rogé cavaillès et enfin
d'un point de vue conceptuel
je trouve que globalement la lumière est
trop focalisée sur les gagnants or
depuis la première cérémonie des césars
en 1976 j'ai compté 3436 perdant de
césar 75% d'entre eux sont décédés de ça
ou d'autres choses
20 % se sont reconvertis dans le
tertiaire et les cinq autres pour cent
sont marina foïs
c'est pourquoi cette année pour
valoriser cette masse majoritaire et
négligé ces individus assoiffés de
revanche de reconnaissance et de vin
j'appelle celle dont quentin tarantino
dit à i don't know bushes celle qui a
été nommée pour le césar de la meilleure
actrice en 2018 et qu'un pas été foutu
de la voir emmanuelle devos